news now breaking news alert good
afternoon thanks so much for joining us
at four on this friday i'm kirsten joyce
and i'm christian gossett as we begin
today with a false alarm at
a henderson elementary school eight news
now reporter orco mana is live near
green valley parkway and the 215 at
vandenberg elementary with more on this
incident oracle what do we know
christian henderson police tell us that
they initially got reports of a
gun here on campus in the parking lot
area but it actually turned out to be a
radar gun so that's one of those
items used by police to track
speedy drivers so again there is no
threat here
at vanderburgh elementary school and the
lockdown has been lifted now these
images
that we're showing you are from about an
hour ago
police just left the scene not too long
ago just in the past 10 minutes or so
but
ccsd police and henderson police were
out here
assessing the situation and they were
also initiating that lockdown again that
lockdown has been lifted
students were able to be picked up
picked up by their parents out here
and again we are here at vanderburgh
elementary school
and again there is no threat here again
henderson police telling us this was a
radar gun
not an actual gun so again for all those
parents out there who might be concerned
just know that there was no threat here
and everyone is safe reporting live
tonight orco mana 8 news now